Hello everybody, this is Dr. Connors and this video is going to help you understand this
binder that you're getting, this three-ring binder that has your protocol in it.
So we're going to go over this.
So this is what your binder looks like, this says kids are protocol binder, a live protocol
binder, whatever you're dealing with.
This is specifically for you.
It is there.
One of the first pages you're going to see is this one.
So this is your specific protocol that I put you on, based upon what we found, you're testing
how I tested you, and so you may or may not have a daily profusion drink, and I will
go over this with you, but it's for you to have that first part of that through, binder
you could take it out, tape it on to your refrigerator where you could home, so you know exactly
what you're going to do on a daily basis.
It's really simple, I try to keep it super simple, so it's not so complicated.
You may put things in a profusion drink, you're going to have a specific diet that will be
later in the binder here, and specific nutritional protocol that you're going to follow, like you're
going to take, you know, curcumin, three per day, or six per day, or you're going to split
those two a day, yes, take two in the morning, two at lunch, two at dinner, or whatever.
And down at the bottom, a bay circle, yes or no on this, whether you're going to continue
with your other supplements, but usually, there's some that I will say don't take, and there's
many that I'll say go ahead and take these, these are good, but after you're done with those,
make sure you let me know so that I can tell you if you want to reorder those or not.
In the binder, you're going to have tabs, what of the tabs is the gut check tab, now you're
going to see if you have it already, a video, a gut check, and why that's so important.
So we go over this, uh, that video, removing foods that cause damage to your gut, and taking
prebiotics, taking probiotics, or whatever else that we might have you do.
So there's a whole video dedicated to that, so I won't spend time on it here.
The other part of the binder is diet, so what are you eating?
So just remember that first page on there says this is a diet, not a religion, so I don't
want you to think that, you know, you're going to die, or it's going to cause your cancer
to grow like crazy if you, you know, had something like, you know, a piece of bacon today, or
something when I had you off a pork, it's not that rigid, but you do want to hold as tightly
to it as possible, so there's going both ways, there's some people think, oh, he said that
he'd eat this, but I only eat it once a day now.
So you can, you can fall, the two liberal or two conservative, you could say, uh, this program,
so I don't want you to be so able that you're going to, it's going to drive you crazy, but
I do want you to follow it as best you can, though you're going to see sheets like this.
So can I eat meat, yes, or no, uh, if, if it's yes, then underneath it, it says something,
so it says it should be grass fed if possible, organic, whatever possible, lamb, buffalo,
elk, lettuce, and beef, goat, or veal, uh, that's what we're talking about when we're talking
about this category of meat.
So try to eat it as close to the way God made it in every thing you do.
That's your general rule of thumb.
So if you're going to eat, if I say yes on eating beef, then you're going to just go to
the grocery store and buy regular hamburger.
It's probably all grade fed, it's probably grade fed with GMO grade, and, uh, you know, there's
just probably a lot of chemicals, maybe additives, calories, maybe, uh, a lot of antibiotics
that are been ejected in these animals, so it's not the best source.
Is it that you can never buy that and eat that because you can't always get grass fed
organic.
I understand that you're just trying to do the best.
Follow me?
So under pork, it says, well, we need to change that should be grass fed, pigs don't eat
grass, so it's not going to be grass fed, but most of the time with cancer patients, we take
them off of pork, so just so you know, pork is not the best thing for anybody to eat, however,
if you don't have cancer, uh, can you eat pork once in a while?
Yes you can.
It's everything within moderation.
You just understand, underneath each one of these headaches, it talks about the best
sources for these different foods.
So even if it's yes, make sure you try to eat it as organically as possible.
Almost everybody can eat as many vegetables as they want, unless, uh, the genetic test,
which we won't find out for a double a week, typically the genetic test that we're going
to have you do it for, we're going to have you do it, it takes about four weeks to get back.
If you do have, let's say, a comp defect, which you don't know what that is yet, I may
take you off chicken and turkey.
If you have a CBS defect, I may take you off some sulfur-containing foods, uh, for a period
of time.
So just to know that any of this diet, they can change what I get some of your other labs
back.
So I'm going to be checking as best as we know how to.
So and then as we get some labs back, we're going to revisit all this.
So if you're from a distance, we're going to talk on the phone of different things that we
might need to do.
So read through these.
I will check off of you, a jug of yours personally, try to do your best to stick to them as best
you can.
Also in here, it says why by organic foods, we understand most of you, although the answer
to this, but everybody's coming from a different place and maybe they don't, you don't understand
what that is.
So read through some of this information too and the things that if you, when you go to the
grocery store that you really, really want to eat organically, those are the clean fruits
and vegetables on the bottom that maybe you could buy that are not organic and then the
ones in the middle of this list, the high pesticide fruits and vegetables are the ones that you
really want to buy organic if whatever possible.
Most people go on a gluten-free diet.
So why?
Because gluten is so highly inflammatory and it's so damaging to your gut.
Now we don't want damage and inflammation in your gut.
That's going to cause inflammation in the rest of your body.
Certainly inflammation in your brain that's going to set off a cascade of problems.
So this little flyer is getting to know gluten.
There's no way we could do a good job of giving you gluten information.
There's just a lot of websites out there that are dedicated to gluten that we just can't
compete with that we refer you to Google, gluten-free eating, gluten-free diet to really get an
understanding of what that is.
Also there's going to be other instructions in here.
Many of you are going to have start uncoffee animals right away.
Many of you, we're not.
Many of you, we will have you do castor oil packs, they are very comforting, they are very
comfortable to do, they're very relaxing, they can be really helpful and drawy toxins out
of your liver.
The reason why you do coffee animals or castor oil packs is really to get your liver detox
pathways going and they can be very beneficial in all sorts of problems.
So that's your binder.
Also in your binder I didn't have a slide of this.
There's a whole section of really looking at the emotional side because every disease has
an emotional component to it.
You cannot ignore it.
So I don't care if you're agnostic or atheist or whatever your belief in your faith is, you
really want to go through that emotional component section and take the little quiz.
It's a little test by yourself, quiet time of the day where you could just be alone with
yourself and with God and ask Him to reveal some things through taking that little test,
that little quiz in there.
You don't share it with me or anybody else but believe me, we've had lots and lots of unbelievable
testimonies of people that have done that, have realized just emotional damage in their
life that wasn't even done by somebody who was trying to emotionally damage them.
So it's just the way they took it as a 7-year-old or a 12-year-old or whatever.
So it can be very, very helpful and so that's a good place to start.
So we were going to be adding stuff to your binder maybe through the course of your treatment
that would be subtracting for your binder.
So this is always to your go-to, so make sure you use this as your go-to.
So in your binder, which I don't have a slide on either, is your instructions for the
RIFE machine.
We read it in instructions for the RIFE so it makes it a little simpler to understand and
card-tax support for a bike to RIFE if you have anything go wrong as well.
All right, hope this helps.